what are her favorite toys because
sometimes that tells you if a child is
advanced well she loves her Elmo doll
and there is I brought a toy that she's
absolutely terrified of that my cousin
gave to her I brought it what is it it's
a I saw them put something back here but
they don't know it's a robotic cat so
the robotic cat and this is you didn't
buy this for your your my cousin my
cousin did and so this cat is what they
give to elderly people with Alzheimer's
because because they can't have a real
cat so he pet it and get it can you see
this it's like opening and closing it
sides and and stay there stay there it
like it's doing well it did open and
close its eyes oh there it goes okay
clearly it's got allergies you know it's
amazing too because it still smells like
urine so she took one look at this and
she was well there you can hear that
it's my parrot / wait and they give this
to elderly people that have cognitive
issues and then you did you gave us to
your child yeah
she's so scared of it yes it's it's
terrifying I have to keep it in my car
now I can't have it in the house so this
is in your car if you can drive in the
carpool lane at least
[Applause]
I might have saved your life since
you're gay I would rather risk the
coronavirus did not get up then be left
hanging on a high-five from a fellow
comic I know crushes me to the core it
just said please kill me
high-five you a make sure we talk about
do you want me to get rid of this and
turn it off or do you wanna sit through
the interview I think now it's got to be
in the interview yeah is this true that
you're in the just chimes in every now
and then randomly yeah I want this cat
here all the time the cat the cat we're
here and just if anything I was having
an interview with anyone and then it
just occasionally started
it's just meowing like it's doing right
now that's fantastic well it also could
be you know those cats that they have in
hospices there's a cat named Oscar that
goes you taking us to such dark place we
just got you Alzheimer's like you know
in hospice there's a CAD need Oscar who
he somehow senses who's the next to go
and he'll go curl up on their bed and
then they'll die like that day so this
could be the cat that tells you whether
or not your ducks about to die what did
they call the cat death finder
I should name the cat before they knew
what it could do
that's a cruel joke to do on someone why
we take a little bit of cat food and if
someone I didn't like how it put your
next I think the patient's find deep
comfort in Oscar okay Conan okay all
right